um thanks so much at this point I feel
like you've heard a lot about this and
Polynesia have placed a lot of trust in
me with this so I'm going to try not to
screw this up too badly so this is a
paper about obviously strategy proof
mechanisms and what this is is it's it's
it's really a formal attempt to classify
dominant strategy mechanisms according
to whether or not they're they are easy
for ordinary people to understand so
this paper starts from the observation
that we often talk about the importance
of having a strategy proof mechanism we
say that they're important for several
reasons strategy proof mechanisms reduce
participation costs because they reduce
the cognitive cost for each agent to
figure out what they should do they
reduce the cost of paying an expert to
tell you what you should do they reduce
the waste from rent-seeking espionage
because if you have a dominant strategy
then your optimal action doesn't change
and so you should you need and spend
money spying on what your opponents are
doing moreover these are said to make
the outcome robust and detail free in
the sense that the outcome that results
in a dominant strategy mechanism doesn't
depend on the agents higher order
beliefs about each other's types or you
know rationality or information now
notice these benefits have just listed
you depends substantially on agents
understanding that the game is strategy
proof and if that they don't understand
this well then these benefits may only
hold to a very reduced degree so that
leads to a very natural question which
is a we know and we've for a while in
economics for about thirty years now
we've said look some strategy proof
mechanisms just are easier for real
people to understand than other strategy
proof mechanisms for instance it's
widely held that ascending clock
auctions are easier to understand than
second price sealed bid auctions now
notice that the existing theory does not
capture this distinction in particular
both these games are strategically
equivalent they have the same reduced
normal form nonetheless there is a body
of experiments he's only the first to in
a very long literature that establish in
essence that lab subjects make large and
systematic errors in second price sealed
bid auctions and these errors persist
even after many rounds of experience
and they by and large get it right in
ascending clock auctions and he gets it
right very quickly requiring very little
experience moreover we've got some
behavioral game theory concepts meant to
model bidders with you know agents with
limited cognitive capacities or make
mistakes but these concepts tend not to
predict errors in strategy proof
mechanisms they tend to predict that if
you have a dominant strategy you play
that strategy so the research question
that I want to answer is when is it
obvious what makes it obvious that a
mechanism is strategy proof and the way
I'm going to answer that is I'm going to
seek a stronger solution concept which I
call obviously strategy proof and we'd
like this to do several things
first we'd like to provide a formal
standard of cognitive simplicity that is
to say we'd like it to take the set of
all strategy proof mechanisms in a very
general class and identify a subset of
those mechanisms as being obvious for
real people to understand we'd like it
to have predictive power we'd like it to
go some distance incorrectly sorting the
cases that people do when don't find
easy to understand and we're going to
try to do this in a parsimonious way and
by that I mean we're going to attempt to
do this using only the standard
primitives that are already found in
classical game theory and while
introducing no new degrees of freedom no
new parameters into the model and of
course because of this I'm not going to
be able to account for every kind of
cognitive complexity for instance it
could be that a mechanism is very
complex if the instructions are given to
you in a foreign language I'm not going
to be able to capture that the hope is
that we capture a kind of cognitive
complexity that explains a substantial
amount of variation in the data so in
this paper I do three things the first
part of this paper is in essence pure
theory I show a new definition which is
a new solution concept obviously
strategy proof which can be interpreted
as an equilibrium in obviously dominant
strategies I then produced two
characterization theorems the first
theorem suggests a behavioral
interpretation to this concept obviously
dominant strategies are the weakly
dominant strategies that can be
recognized as weakly dominant by a
cognitively limited agent for a
well-defined sense of cognitively
limited the second theorem suggests a
classical interpretation in particular
obviously strategy proof mechanisms are
those that can be run even when the
planner lacks full commitment
or but can only make commitments between
that that planner and an agent that are
bilaterally verifiable then there's the
second part of the paper where in
essence I check whether or not the
theory is any empirical bite I compare
in a lab experiment strategy proof and
obviously strategy proof mechanisms that
according to the standard theory should
implement the same allocation rule and
what I find in essence is that dominant
strategies are played at substantially
higher rates under OSP mechanisms than
under otherwise very similar mechanisms
that are just SP and the last part of
the paper is applied theory I go to a
classic mechanism design setting binary
allocation problems these include
private value options with unit demand
procurement options with unit supply
binary public goods games and I
characterize fully the OSP mechanisms
and provide necessary and sufficient
conditions for you to OSP implement an
allocation rule now this is too
ambitious for a 30-minute talk I'm going
to try to cover just this first bit and
if you interested in any of the latter
bits you can have a look at the paper so
with all that said I'd better give you a
definition in this talk we're going to
think of mechanisms as extensive game
forms with perfect recall and we're
going to say that a strategy is
obviously dominant if for all deviating
strategies at any earliest information
set where these two strategies diverge
the best possible outcome under the
deviation is no better than the worst
possible outcome under the original
strategy now remember these are
extensive games so strategies are
complete contingent cleanse of action
they specify what you do at any
information set where you might be
called to play now we're going to say
that a mechanism is obviously strategy
proof if it is an equilibrium in
obviously dominant strategies now this
is a definition in words but I'd like to
make sure we're on the same page so
we're going to build this up formally
now this function alpha I'm going to use
to pick out the earliest points of
departure of two strategies yep
so how would a second-price auction so a
second-price auction is an extensive
form game where we have simultaneous
moves and we represented as you make
your bid and I make a bid without
knowing what your bid is yeah when you
see the worst possible outcome the
students that in these other parts of
the game you follow your own strategy so
it's not worst according to your own
possible mistakes in that party yeah
yeah so we're going to make these
precise this will be very clear in a
moment um yeah I think that for obvious
you'd like to put in some computational
caveat in the definition and check ibly
so right right and and I'd like to have
that but I worry that that would reduce
the concepts tractability that's
certainly an interesting extension I
just haven't done that so I'm going to
use this function alpha to pick out the
earliest points of departure of two
strategies these are the information
sets where strategies first come apart
so an information set is an earliest
point of departure if and only if first
both strategies disagree about what
action to take at that information set
and second both strategies do not rule
out reaching that information set now
here I've got a standard extensive game
I've got a read strategy for player two
and a blue strategy for player two there
are four information sets where these
strategies disagree about what to do
which of these are earliest points of
departure they're these two in green why
isn't that one over there an earliest
point of departure well because the blue
strategy rules I'll ever reach in that
information set and why isn't this one
over here in the earliest point of
departure
well because both strategies rule out
ever reaching that information set so
notice this function alpha picks out
takes as an input two strategies and
picks out a set of information sets
there could be more than one and it does
so without prior reference to what your
opponent is doing so I'm going to use
this as the one bit of notation I really
need this thing here is the utility to
agent I in some game G when we start
play from some history H when play
proceeds according to this strategy
profile s is - I
when the realization of chance moves is
DC so we're dealing with general
extensive games that can be notes that
are assigned to chance that's like a
strategy for the chance player and the
resulting outcome is evaluated according
to preferences theta I so we're in a
private value world you're only a few
yes yes yes the SS appear although it
turns out you can generalize this to max
without too much difficulty so I'm going
to use h0 to refer to the history that
begins the game and I'm going to use
Delta C to refer to the probability
measure for chance moves so far this is
all very standard so over here up top
I've got the standard definition for
weak dominance written for extensive
form games and on the bottom I've got
the definition for obvious dominance now
I'm sure this crowd has pretty much all
seen this definition many times before
but a strategy is weakly dominant if for
deviating strategies and for all
opponent strategy profiles the expected
payoff under the deviation is no better
than the expected payoff under the
original strategy and the strategy is
obviously dominant if for all deviating
strategies at any information set that's
an earliest point of departure the best
possible outcome under the deviation
going forward is no better than the
worst possible outcome under the
original strategy now it may not be
transparent just yet but I hope it will
be soon obvious dominance implies weak
dominance this is a strictly stronger
criterion now there are two differences
between these definitions that I'd like
to point out to you the first difference
is that weak dominance invokes h0 the
history that begins the game and what
this means is that weak dominance
depends only on the normal form of the
game if two games have the same normal
form then they have the same weakly
dominant strategies obvious dominance
looks at histories that are in
information sets that are earliest
points of departure and this depends
crucially on the extensive form of a
game two games could have the same
normal form but one game could have
obviously dominant strategies and the
other might not and what this means is a
corollary is that the standard
revelation principle does not apply to
obvious dominance if you take an obvious
obviously dominant strategies and you
convert that into the corresponding
direct revelation mechanism that may or
may not preserve obvious dominance the
second difference I'd like to point out
to you is that weak dominance holds the
histories the opponent strategies and
the realizations of chance the same
across both sides of this inequality
where as obvious dominance looks at the
best case on the left hand side and
compares the worst case on the right
hand side and notice these are the best
in the worst case subject to having
reach the information sets where you're
thinking of deviating now with that it
turns out that we can answer the
original question that I was posing what
is obvious about ascending auctions
that's not obvious about second price it
turns out that second price sealed bid
auctions are strategy proof but they
aren't obviously strategy proof and to
see that here's a simplified second
price auction first player one either
bit 0 2 or 4 and then player 2 bids 1 3
or 5 and let's suppose player 2's value
is $3 so that in blue the truth-telling
strategy is to bid $3 now one thing
player 2 we could do is to deviate he
could deviate to bid $5 and that's a
deviating strategy down there in red now
what's the earliest point of departure
of these two strategies pretty clearly
it's this information set over here in
green now what's the best possible
outcome under the deviation consistent
with reaching this information set well
player one could bid 0 in which case
player 2 will win the object at a price
of zero for a surplus of 3 now what's
the worst possible outcome that can
happen under the truth-telling strategy
consistent with reaching this
information set while player 1 could bid
for in which case player 2 won't win so
notice the best outcome on the deviation
is better than the worst outcome under
the original strategy and what this
shows of course is that second price
sealed bid auctions are strategy proof
but they're not obviously strategy proof
on the other hand it turns out that
ascending auctions are obviously
strategy proof and the way to see that
again takes the simplified example we
start the price at 0 and we ask player 1
are you in or out
then we raise the price by a dollar and
we ask player 2 are you in or out then
we raise the price by a dollar and we go
back to player 1 and so on and so on
down the game tree
now again let's suppose plant whose
value is $3 so that the truth-telling
strategy in blue is the bid on so the
price it's $3 and then to quit and let's
look at that same deviation in red to
bid until the price hits $5 and then
quit now what's the earliest point of
departure of these two strategies well
that's pretty easy it's this information
set over here in green now what's the
best possible outcome from player two's
perspective conditional on reaching this
information set under the deviation or
remember player two's value is $3 and
once he's hit this information set the
prices just shot past $3 so from his
perspective the best thing that can
happen is that player one keeps bidding
and he doesn't win right so the best the
best possible outcome under the
deviation is that player to get 0 now
what's the worst possible outcome under
the original strategy consistent with
reaching this information set well
that's pretty easy there's only one
outcome that could happen which is that
clear to doesn't win so notice the best
outcome under the deviation is no better
than the worst outcome under the
original strategy and what this shows of
course you can see this argument
generalizes is that ascending options
have not only dominant strategies they
have obviously dominant strategies they
fulfill a strictly stronger solution
concept than second price auctions - now
so far so good
I've shown you a new definition and I've
shown you which sorts the case which
otherwise looks quite puzzling but it's
quite a reasonable question to ask what
makes obvious dominance obvious why is
this like an appropriate thing yeah
right you take the soup in in food
respect to the randomness what will turn
out that that's important for a second
equivalents and I'm going to get to in a
bit there's the second equivalence that
only holds if you do it that way nature
is another player nature is another
player and this is the this is not a
novel idea that nature is another player
which is taking it seriously here as
well so I'm going to show you in fact
that this definition of obvious 'no siz
precisely that picked out by a formal
model of a cognitively limited agent and
the model i have in mind is motivated by
a separate set of empirical facts which
is that there's a growing body of lab
evidence suggesting that contingent
reasoning is hard for many people to do
and what i mean by that is that there's
these lab these lab experiments document
systematic errors in real money decision
problems that are attributable to
mistakes in case-by-case reasoning that
is to say when you're making a decision
you have to think about different
hypothetical scenarios that have not
occurred yet and you have to integrate
this information somehow to reach the
optimal decision now i don't have time
to cover each of these experiments in
detail and i'm happy to talk about them
offline
what i want to take away from that is to
figure out a way to model agents who
make these kinds of mistakes and how can
we do that well let's think about these
two games in these games player 1
chooses lor and then player 2 chooses Y
or Z and I've highlighted the only
differences between these two games in
red now suppose player 1 prefers outcome
a to B to C to D in that case then
playing L is weakly dominant strategy in
game 1 but not a weakly dominant
strategy in game 2 now in order to see
the L is weakly dominant in game 1
player one needs the reason
hypothetically needs the reason
case-by-case he needs to say look there
are two things that could happen either
two plays Y or two plays E and if two
plays Y then I should play L since I
prefer A to B and if to play Z then I
should play L since I prefer C to D
therefore I should play L no matter what
player 2 is doing now notice that if
player one is bad at contingent
isn't bad at keeping track of these
cases then he might know that playin L
could lead to a or C and playing or
could lead to B or D but he wouldn't be
able to distinguish these games as
though he can't tell these games apart
so we're going to take find a formal
technology to say play one can tell
games like this apart in the way we do
that as we invoke the notion of an
experience this is a thing we use in the
theory of extensive games define perfect
recall the experience of an agent I at
history H records the information sets
where that agent was called to play and
the actions that that agent took in
chronological order so this is a
sequence that says I was at this
information set and took this action
then was at this information set and
took that action and so on and so on and
so on I'm going to denote such a thing
sigh I now notice that in a sense both
the games we were looking at generate
the same experiences for player one in
both games if player one was at his
information set and didn't choose
anything then he knows the game isn't
going to end yet if he was at his
information set and chose left then he
knows that the game could end and if it
does and it ends in a or C and he knows
that if he was at that information set
and chose right then he knows that if
the game ends it ends in B or D so to
say that player one can't tell these two
games apart we could say play one can
tell games that generate the same
experiences apart so we're going to take
that notion and make it fully general
for all extensive games with perfect
recall and the way we do that is we say
two games G and G prime generate the
same experiences for a player I if there
exists a bijection lambda from i's
information sets in actions in g on to
i's information sets and actions in g
prime such that something is an
experience in g if and only if it's by
ejected version is an experience in g
prime and something could an experience
could lead to an outcome in G even only
if it's by ejected version could lead to
that same outcome in G prime now this is
an equivalence relation clearly and it
defines a partition on the set of all
mechanisms so what does it mean to say
that agents can't distinguish games that
generate the same experiences well this
partition retains substantial knowledge
about the structure of the game the
agent knows all the points where he
might be called to play he knows for any
point he might
be called to play what actions are
available he knows for any sequence of
points he was called to play in actions
that he took whether or not the game
might end and if so what outcomes it
might end at the thing he lacks is the
information necessary to reason
case-by-case about what his opponents
are doing so so far we've taken the
space of all games let's suppose every
dot is a game and we've defined a
partition we said agents can't
distinguish games that generate the same
experiences now suppose that some
strategy was weakly dominant in one game
but it's by ejected version was not
weakly dominant in other games in that
equivalence class then it won't be
obvious to our agent that that strategy
is dominant because he can't tell that
game apart from other games which
require contingent reasoning to
distinguish on the other hand suppose
that a strategy is dominant not only in
one game but in every game in that
equivalence class in every nearby game
according to this well-defined sense of
nearby then it's going to be obvious to
our agent that that strategy is dominant
even though he doesn't understand these
particular details of the game and the
first characterization theorem in
essence says we're entitled to remove
the quotation marks a strategy is
obviously dominant according to that
definition I showed you earlier in some
game G if and only if for all games that
generate the same experiences for is G
that strategy the by ejected version is
weakly dominant in G Prime now how does
this proof work essentially what you
show is that if a strategy is not
obviously dominant in G you can take a
sequence of transformations of that game
never leaving the equivalence class to
produce a game where that strategy is
not weakly dominant and the other way
goes that if a strategy is not weakly
dominant in G prime then you can in fact
locate an earliest information set where
that agent would like to deviate and you
can take you can look back through this
bi action to locate a point in the
original game G where the obvious
dominance inequality doesn't hold so
what this is saying is look rather than
modeling agents who understand every
detail of every game these agents
understand some details of the game but
not others and the strategy is a can
nonetheless verified to be weakly
dominant are the ones
are obviously dominant so that's one
notion of what this thing is doing but
here's a separate notion that's
classical I'm going to show you that a
notion of what the planner can do when
she has only partial commitment power is
in fact coextensive with the notion of
OSP implementation and so let's think
about the standard mechanism design
paradigm one of the very deep
assumptions in the standard paradigm is
that the planner has full commitment
power the planner writes down the game
and that's what's going to happen in
particular we assume that the planner
can make commitments even about events
that no individual agent observes for
instance in a sealed bid auction we
assume that the planner can commit to
the function from all bid profiles into
allocations even if each agent only
observes his own bid now sometimes
that's a realistic assumption and
sometimes it's not a realistic
assumption and it'd be good to know what
happens if we relax that assumption and
we've known this for a while for
instance in victories original paper he
points out that if you don't have a
trusted third party to run the sealed
bid auction then the auctioneer might be
tempted to insert your bids sourced out
to his revenues and there's a 21st
century of this problem 21st century
version of this problem which you
basically see in all morning which is if
your algorithm has to attempt over a
hundred thousand np-complete problems in
the course of the auction then it might
be quite hard for bidders to verify what
you're doing it might be quite costly
and you tell them this is what you're
doing they may or may not believe you so
notice that it seems like this
distinction also appears to track the
second price versus ascending auction
distinction in particular in a second
price sealed bid auction if the
auctioneer might peek at the bids and
then insert show bids you probably
shouldn't bid your true value you should
probably shade your bid a bit on the
other hand in an ascending clock auction
suppose I tell you look this is the
price the price is at $10 and you say
you're out now you're definitely out if
you say you're in maybe you win at $10
or maybe I'll raise the price and ask
you again now a lot of other things
could be going on the rest of this
auction right a lot of things would be
going on with the other bidders that you
have no idea about
but looking only at this bilateral
guarantee you know that you should keep
bidding on sort of price hits your value
and then you should quit and you know as
you can see from the talks earlier this
morning it turns out that every deferred
acceptance auction with threshold
pricing
has a clerk auction implementation and
that turns out importantly relates to
the idea of partial commitment so how
can we make this notion precise the
planner has less than partial cim less
than full commitment power well here's
one way I don't claim it's the only way
but I think it's a natural way we're
going to add in addition to the set of
agents n player zero the planner and the
way this game works is the planner
chooses some agent and sends along a
message along with a set of acceptable
replies the agents observe this the
agent observes this and then chooses a
reply the planner observes a reply and
again and can either then choose to
repeat the above process potentially
with someone else or can announce an
outcome and end the game now it should
be fairly apparent that using this sort
of machinery I can essentially run any
extensive game that moves in discrete
steps now I'm going to use size 0 to
denote the set of all planner strategies
these strategies tell the planner you
know what messages to send what replies
to regard is acceptable which message to
send next as a function of the replies
she's already gotten when to end the
game what outcome to announce when the
game ends and I intend size zero to
include even the MEXT strategy so the
planner could be running a random
mechanism where she's randomizing
between different options now the
standard full commitment paradigm says
the planner commits to a unique strategy
in the set of all her strategies but we
can instead require only bilateral
commitments and what does that mean it
means that for each agent the planner
commits to a subset of her strategies
where that subset is measurable with
respect to eyes observations in the game
and what I mean by that is that if the
planner plays a strategy outside this
subset then with positive probability
that agent might know for certain that
the planner has deviated so notice this
is potentially a different subset for
each agent and the planner gets choose a
profile of these things now we're going
to say that a choice rule is supported
by bilateral commitments one for each
agent of three things hold the first
requirement is that there exists planner
strategy a planner strategy and agent
strategies that result in the outcome
that the choice rule requires I mean
this this has got to be in there
somewhere the second requirement is that
full for all agents the planners
strategy is compatible
the commitment that agent has been
offered this is saying these commitments
are binding the third requirement is
that for all agents agent i's strategy
is optimal given any strategies from the
other agents and any planner strategy
compatible jest agent i's bilateral
commitment so the thought is looking
only at the bilateral commitment agent i
has been offered i must be able to
deduce the optimality of his assigned
strategy now it seems like a natural
question then goes when do there exists
bilateral commitments that support a
choice rule and the following holds and
for generality a choice rule can be
supported by bilateral commitments even
only if that choice rules OSP
implementable and this might seem a bit
of an unusual result but the key
intuition works like this a bilateral
commitment is almost equivalent it's not
quite there are some technical issues to
do with sets of measure zero but it's
almost equivalent to the planner saying
I'm only going to run games in some
equivalence class that generate the same
experiences for you so when is it the
case that no matter what strategy the
planner is playing you can know that
your strategy is optimal or your
strategy has got to be dominant not only
in this game but in every game that
generates the same experiences by the
first theorem we know that's true even
only if it's an obviously dominant
strategy so it turns out that in
addition to having a behavioral
interpretation the notion of OSP
implementation in fact tracks a
classical interpretation it tracks the
set of choice rules that you can carry
out when you have only bilateral
commitment power when you can only write
down commitment contracts of a form that
you and that agent could verify
bilaterally
so I've only managed to get through the
first third of this paper and I'm not
going to be able to get through all of
the remainder but just as a preview it
does seem like this concept does track
the cases where people find it easy to
play a game versus the cases where
people find it difficult obviously I
haven't exhaustively search space of all
games but it does seem to have some
empirical bite and classifying things
correctly and it turns out that in the
sort in the set of binary allocation
problems so you've got a single
dimensional type you've got you know
you've got quasi linear utility there
are transfers every OSP mechanism is
essentially a monotone price mechanism
which is a new generalization of
ascending clock auctions so what this
says in essence is that this compact
criterion this requirement of obvious
dominance by itself entails not all but
quite a lot of the structure of what
goes into an ascending auction if you
don't have binary allocation problems if
you look at more general environments
this is not true there are in fact more
exotic OSP mechanisms that are out there
so I think you know I've spoken quite a
lot I feel like I really like to take
questions and get people sensing this
I'd be happy to open to questions
yeah I worry that the solution concept
might not be quite strong enough okay I
worry that is that it seems like you
fight very carefully about agents being
limited in contingent reasoning not
being able to look back up the tree yeah
but you don't seem to have fun as
carefully about agents will be limited
and looking down the tree yeah now you
think that they can they can evaluate
this inequality regardless of the
downstream complexity of the tree and
all the examples you give an obscure
this by making really obvious as soon as
you're at a branch point something
immediately happens yeah I wonder if you
think that there could be an amount of
complexity down the tree where an agent
would have trouble doing the
verification oh yeah yep so here's an
example of a game with an obviously
dominant strategy which probably where
the theory probably gets it wrong if you
give me the first hundred digits of pi
inorder I'll give you one hundred
dollars and zero dollars otherwise now I
suspect that this has an obviously
dominant strategy I suspect most of us
would fail to in fact get the hundred
dollars
somebody might this is not an actual
offer but it's clear that there are some
forms of complexity this is not going to
capture and sometimes those are going to
be important forms I'm worried that a
lot of stuff happens after my move yep
essentially a contingent reasoning
downstream I just don't think of it well
so what you need to do is you need to
know what might happen following one
move and what might happen following
another you need to be able to list the
possible outcomes and check that they
have a set wise dominance relation
rather than in a state wise dominance
relation so the thought is rather than
needing sort of match up for each
opponent strategy profile this move is
better than that move you can just say
look it doesn't matter what my opponent
strategy profiles are this set is set
wise dominates that set and that's a
sense in which it's easier but sometimes
that could still be hard to calculate
I say one more thing but you're sort of
appealing to the idea that the game
itself is on base yep the PI game it had
a very succinct description so you're
able to tell it to me yeah I'm worried
that the game tree itself is so complex
and it it happens to be well can we get
over gaming like that that's true though
the TV station side of the incentive
auction also is a very long description
length the the the neat fact feature of
it being obviously strategy proof is
that to get you to see your dominant
strategy a partial description sufficed
and I you know I don't have a formal way
to make that statement yet but there is
a sense in which partial description
suffice in the sense you only need to
know up to the class that generate the
same experiences yeah so to find this
notion obviously strategy proof and I'm
wondering if there is a reason that you
need to focus on strategy proof like it
obviously is an adjective that you could
say this is obviously a Nash equilibrium
so the thing I'd like to say next and I
haven't found the technology to say it
yet is this is an obvious ex post
equilibrium I think that would be a
useful thing to have but I haven't found
the right way to do it if anybody else
wants to have a stab as well you know I
you know this distantly isn't something
that I think I can manage completely on
my own here
so thanks on running on one of the nice
properties you get by this obviously
saying that even in you expect what
other agents are doing so right right
then you're still sort of is right it's
sort of an adversarial notion like that
right we don't think of the other guys
Paget depending on yours but only
through them but somehow it means that
you're sort of I mean do you have
something that shows it you know I don't
care what I what kind of information I
give to the others or anything like that
that's sort of equivalent notion man I I
don't yet I I think there might be a
characterization that says if you allow
interchanging the order of simultaneous
moves and obviously dominant strategy is
one where even if you interchange orders
of moves and every agent perfectly
observed what you did it's still a
dominant strategy but that's that that's
a conjecture rather than in a formal
statement